as nelson mandela said
education
is the most powerful weapon you can use
to change the world
wherever you are right now listening to
this i want you to burn that into your
mind the most powerful weapon that
you're going to have at your disposal
isn't a gun it isn't a sword it isn't a
bomb the most powerful weapon you will
ever have at your disposal if you really
want to make change
is knowledge
it doesn't mean going to school it can
be school it can be books it can be a
mentor it can be somebody else's failure
it can be your own
failure
but whatever it is to always be learning
to be learning something today knowing
that that's an investment and as robert
louis stevenson said don't
judge each day by the harvest you reap
but rather by the seeds you plant and
that's what knowledge is that's what the
learning process is is you're learning
something today that you may not even
understand how it's going to be valuable
but one day
that piece of knowledge is going to come
to your aid one day that thing that you
learned is going to be something that
you're going to lean on one day that
thing that you've worked your ass off to
understand better than anybody else in
the world
it's going to help you change
the world
but you have to be doing it now you have
to be learning with an obsession you
have to understand that ideas in equal
ideas out and that you have to chase
that knowledge down that it is a
relentless pursuit and that like you
would build an armada like you would
create a stock pile of weapons you must
create a stockpile of knowledge you must
learn and learn and learn and you must
hold yourself accountable every day to
planting those seeds to getting better
to learning more to understanding things
more broadly when you do that there will
be nothing that won't be unlocked to you
that's what i want you guys to
understand it doesn't matter where you
are now it doesn't matter where you
started your circumstances the money the
people that you know none of it matters
what matters is how much you're willing
to learn how good are you willing to get
how much knowledge are you willing to
soak in because that
will become your weapon that will be how
you rise up and that will be the thing
that will protect you when you need it
most if you're feeling helpless one of
the antidotes to feeling helpless is to
get more help full
and one of the ways you can be most
helpful is to raise your own identity
our identity is the core part of our
lives we're not going to outperform our
identity our identity
best set is
it's the thoughts concepts and beliefs
we hold to be the most true about
ourselves
it's really the invisible force in all
of our lives that holds us back or can
accelerate our success our bliss our
achievements to whole new levels if you
look at identity if you think about it
it's almost like it's the it's a life
thermostat see in this room right now
there's a thermostat sitting on that
wall right now and if it's set at 75
degrees this room is going to be
regulated to 75 degrees no matter what
the external conditions are it could be
100 degrees outside the external factors
do not impact the internal thermostat in
this room it's 75 degrees consequently
also if it was 40 degrees outside the
heater will come on it'll heat this room
to 75 degrees that's how your identity
works
it's the internal thermostat of your
life
and that's why very often let's say that
you know relationships or financially
you're a 75 degree
and if you ever notice in your life as
you start to heat life up a little bit
starts to go pretty well maybe your
relationship's blissful and loving and
incredible or financially you've
increased your results you're at 80 85
90 100 degrees of success financially or
in business and then it just seems
coincidental but somehow some way
the air conditioner kicks on in our
lives you know a car breaks down an
event happens we lose an account
something takes place and all of a
sudden we look up and boom life's back
at 75 degrees of relationship of money
of business
that wasn't by coincidence
it is the regulator of your life is your
identity and so if you you can do all
the right things all the activities all
of the thinking all of the execution
part but if you don't increase what you
believe you're worth if you don't
increase that identity that thermostat
of your life you will find a way to cool
your life back down to what you believe
you deserve and so one of the keys for
me in my life is not just getting better
at the mindset of life and the execution
of business or strategy but raising that
identity so that i'm at 85 90 100 120
degrees so that i believe i'm worthy of
as my execution and my thinking reaches
the same level that thermostat setting
that life setting will change
it's not the external conditions of our
life that dictate the terms it's that
identity it's that thermostat setting so
we got to get more helpful if we feel
helpless and the way we do that is by
increasing our own identity that
thermostat setting that sounds great
doesn't it so how do you do that well i
call it the holy trilogy of shifting
one's identity and that is faith
intention and association that's the
three things you must work on in order
to increase your thermostat setting
number one faith for me it's the center
part of my life is that i have a god who
loves me that believes in me that wants
to see me successful wants to see me
prosper
wants to have favor in my life wants me
to feel comfort and peace
and so i find oftentimes interesting
people of faith sometimes god's in their
life sunday at church when they're
worshiping or they're in bible study or
when they're eating a meal they'll pray
over it but somehow when they walk into
a business meeting a speech a board room
a client environment they leave god at
the door and they think they're on their
own
so for me if you're a person of faith
and god is with you all the time
and he loves you all the time and he
comforts you all the time that includes
business that includes every area of
your life it includes him wanting to
bless you with a great relationship
bless you financially bless you to the
best of your abilities in business and
then whatever the other if you're an
athlete watching this bless you in that
at bat over that pot catching that
football hitting that shot
and so number one source of shifting
your thermostat setting is reconnecting
again with your faith and allowing
yourself to feel it inside all the other
environments that exist then there's
number two there's your intentions see i
don't think enough people give
themselves credit for having great
intention there's a power to intention
in our lives and so what most of us
think is i'll feel better about myself
or i'll be more confident when
when i get that job when i get that
relationship when i get this amount of
money when i get that house when i hit
that home run when i'm hitting a certain
average
right and so you're always chasing your
tail if your identity and your
confidence is contingent upon producing
a result that has not yet existed
it's pretty difficult to catch it isn't
if you have to have it to get it in the
first place instead of saying
maybe i ought to get credit and i ought
to be worthy of more because i intend to
do well as a young man in business i
started to figure out you know i i may
not have all the answers i may not be
the smartest the best looking the most
articulate my iq isn't 250
but i intend to serve
i intend to make a difference i make
mistakes but overall i'm a good person
who wants to do good in the world and i
should be favored because of that
not enough of you are giving yourself
credit for your intentions you want to
shift your identity overnight connect
with your faith you want to double shift
it connect with your intentions so when
i go into a business meeting or i go
into a lunch or i'm going into any type
of encounter even in my golf life when
my sport i play i remind myself that
i've got a god who loves me who wants me
to win and wants me to be blessed who
wants me to be favored wants me to feel
peace number two
i intend to do good i'm a decent human
being and you know what good things
ought to happen to good people and then
third is association you are who you
hang around see if you're a
85 degree or a 75 degree or financially
but you start hanging around someone say
like myself who lives at 100 to 40 150
degrees of finances and wealth and
abundance you will get heated up by
proximity to somewhere in between the
two of us and a lot closer to where i am
than where you are
same thing in relationships if you want
to have a great loving relationship in
your life but you're living at 75
degrees in your relationships you start
hanging around people who are in loving
beautiful relationships your thermostat
setting will increase same within your
faith life if you want to start walking
with more faith in your 75 degrees of
faith if you start hanging around people
who walk their faith life at 150 degrees
you'll be heated up through proximity
and so these are the three things we do
in order to shift our lives our identity
is the governor on our life it is the
most powerful force in the world it's
the invisible force that governs
everything is that thermostat setting
and then if that's true the way we shift
it is always going to be our faith our
intentions and our associations in life
there's only one way for you to really
truly have your labor be fulfilling a
you have to align with what's most
important to you what you really believe
in what's meaningful for you that if you
settle for something less than that well
you might have to do it because you have
to pay your bills you can't ever give up
pursuing what's going to make you feel
most alive because
ultimately i really believe
that the
probably the most i don't know the most
sacred thing in our lives that we can
give another human being besides our
love is our labor
you think about your labor is your
energy it's your time it's your emotion
it's your intellect it's your spirit to
some extent and if you can find a way
where
what you do for a living activates that
sense of what you're made for then work
is not work whether you be in fiji or
whether you be in a an environment that
might be seen less exciting and
promising in the moment trust me i've
worked in plenty of those too but with
the same level of excitement and passion
because i found what
turns me on that makes me feel alive
makes me feel like i'm doing something
that's worthwhile and on labor day i
think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
labor uh and my hope is to trigger you
to think about how could you turn your
labor into your love
i think it was uh mark twain who said
when your vocation becomes your vacation
that's when life becomes truly
magnificent and i'm privileged enough to
have that but i pursued it and one of
the secrets that i found and i know you
know this in your soul is that we all
know if you're going to be masterful at
something you don't show up you know as
the best in the world at something you
don't show up in environments that you
want to be in you get there because you
did things for thousands and thousands
of hours most of you know the concept of
mastery taking 10 000 hours that's an
arbitrary number but i'm sure you've
heard about you want to get really good
at something it's 10 000 hours because
when you do something enough with enough
intensity enough intention to constantly
get better when your labor is your love
and where your labor is something you
have to always get better at
then usually what happens is you get
these insights that allow you to serve
more but i also think that labor you
know we're talking about this weekend
what makes people fulfilled by their
labor is
is their motives for it if your motive
is just to make money or just to pay
your bills or
or just to get rich or whatever you
think that's going to be those people
never really are fulfilled even if they
make the money um the most fulfilled
human beings in my experience and i've
had the privilege of working with
literally four million people from 125
countries now around the world the
people that are most alive regardless of
the economics are people that have found
something that they really feel the
motive is more than just themselves you
know we all know what it feels like when
you're trying to do so for something for
someone you love and you're not doing it
as a trade you're not trying to get
something back you're just doing it
because it's what you're made for and
i always tell people motive does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because
life supports whatever else supports
life if you're part of life and you're
trying to do something it's going to
make your life better i think the
universe god whatever proper term for
you whatever your belief system is
you know
infinite intelligence gets connected to
you and it gives you insights
but i think if you're trying to serve
more than yourself more life than just
you
when things support more of life more of
life shows up to support you and that
might sound kind of airy fairy but it's
my experience you know when you're
trying to support your family when
suddenly i had four kids three of them
overnight
my life changed my intellect changed my
abilities changed because i was trying
to serve something more than just me
uh when i started really focusing how to
serve a community and then a country and
then humanity as corny as it may sound
um you get insights you won't get when
you're just trying to somehow you know
make your labor happen or get the job
done
so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people i think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at
labor as work uh they look at as why
should i have to effort so much and in
my experience effort is the reward if
you are doing something you love it's
there so if you don't have it you might
say tony that's all wonderful you're in
fiji and you do what you love and i
don't have that thanks so much for
giving me the lecture
i'm not coming from that place i'm come
from the place of saying you can
discover something that you're really
passionate about but in order to do it
you got to get out of the story of what
you can't do and you've got to put
yourself on the line if you can get
yourself to love to do the stuff you
hate to do then there's no limit to the
success you can have in your life
if you can take the things that you're
afraid you'd have to do to succeed in
your business or to succeed in your life
or
to succeed in your relationship there
are things everybody doesn't want to do
and the more focused you're on how
you're not going to do that the more
life seems to bring those things up for
you and makes them barriers
so maybe on labor day maybe it's time to
take something that you can't stand
doing and saying you know i'm gonna do
this for two hours i'm gonna find a way
to love the hell out of it and if you
did you might find a little breakthrough
you might find that if you're in the
moment with anything
and you tap into your ability to enjoy
anything in life and you just focus on
what you can give instead of what you
can get
and that state of giving
work disappears
and doesn't matter if you're by the
ocean or in the desert it doesn't matter
with um whether people even thank you or
not honestly as much as we all enjoy
people's gratitude when you've done
something really well and you know it
doesn't matter what everybody else says
you know who you are you know what
you've become you know what you've given
in the end
even people seem to be selfish inside we
all are yearning for something more in
ourselves we're yearning to
feel like our life matters
and i see people all the time it makes
me choke up who are just working their
tail off innate
and they're just so focused on the work
that they've forgotten that it's a gift
they can give sometimes that gift is
just their joy sometimes that gift is
your attention sometimes that gift
is a level of effort that's
extraordinary so the research as i
mentioned at university college of
london says it takes 66 days for any
human being to wire any in a in a habit
and we all have a gift called
neuroplasticity so we all can do it and
then the model i i share in the book is
called the habit installation protocol
and basically it's 22 days called
installation excuse me called
destruction
to get up early you've got to destroy
your old neural patterns and emotional
signatures of getting up later
that doesn't happen in an instant all
change is hard at first messy in the
middle
gorgeous at the end so that first
destruction phase is 22 days there's
nothing wrong society says it's hard so
it's bad i'm suggesting it's hard so
it's good that's what real change is as
you with that awareness you can stay
with it and get into the second phase
which is
installation
and that's like a house renovation which
is messy and that's why change is messy
in the middle
your old pathways and ways of being are
falling apart but
you know this because i sense you have a
very deep grounding in that middle part
you have to
in some ways let go of who you were it's
called a dark night of the soul
so for 22 days it's it's messy in the
middle because you're letting go of who
you were that's not easy and that's why
habit installation you need to have some
bravery but that's only 22 days stay
with it because then you get to the
third phase which is implementation so
destruction integration
implementation well now we're on the
short roads and the neuroplasticity has
kicked in and
the researchers call it automaticity you
will every human being can get to a
place 66 days later approximately where
it actually gets easier to get up at 5am
than to stay in the bed and the point is
it's called automaticity and that's it
you know we all have that ability we
just need to stay with that three-stage
process for 66 days a blockage or
barrier
it's a situation or circumstances where
something external to you
makes your forward movement difficult or
impossible it's outside of you so it may
be something you need it may be a
requirement or regulation sometimes it
could be a person okay
it really could be
now here's the thing about blockages and
barriers
so that you can find the opportunity
blockages and barriers can be
navigated
they really can be
you might need some support
or some a different additional
information
you might need to get creative
but most barriers indicate that you may
have moved forward
without complete or inadequate
information that's all a blockage or
barrier is
you need support or you may have moved
forward without complete information now
here's the good thing
barriers and blockages teach you
patience and creativity
who knew that
who knew that you could learn patience
and creative approaches to a problem
when you have a barrier or a blockage in
your way
and in many cases in many cases the
purpose of a barrier or a blockage is
about
timing that's how it teaches you
patience okay so when there's an
obstacle external to you something
that's preventing you from moving
forward something that's required look
for information look for support and
learn to be patient there is a fear
in the root
of everything you call an obstacle
there is a fear
in the root
of everything you determine is an
obstacle
there's a fear
that something we have will be lost or
taken away
there's a fear that the difficulty that
we're facing either won't go away or
will get worse
there's a fear that will be made to look
foolish or inadequate there's a fear
that we will disappoint someone there's
a fear that someone we love and respect
will the point disappoint us there's a
fear that what we're doing what we want
what we've done is not pleasing to god's
source creator there's a fear that we
will be or are being punished for
something we have done or not gone there
is a fear
at the root
of everything you call an obstacle take
a breath
that's why it's important for you to
know the purpose of those common
perspectives of obstacles so that you
can shift into the purpose of the thing
and not get lost in the fear of it god
is in everything i see because god is in
my mind
god
is in everything i see
because god is in my mind
so if you're seeing it just as an
optical shift and get called into your
god mind
so that you can see the opportunity that
exists there
yeah when i when i did a little research
on this lesson you know god is in
everything i see
because god is in my mind what does that
mean god is love god is life god is
light
that means listen beloveds listen
there's a light in my mind
a light i tend to ignore
a light i tend to
limit a light i tend to disbelieve in
this light is a higher level of
consciousness
and if i interact with this level of
consciousness instead of making my own
interpretations i will experience my
world in a different way because god is
in everything i see
because god is in my mind
so obstacles are a call for us beloved
to do something different opportunities
they humble you they humble you
obstacles will humble you they take you
out of the inflated ego of being human
you don't know everything you can't do
everything you can't see everything
and when you face an obstacle you get
clear about that
and it's also an obstacle is an
opportunity for transformation changing
what is into a greater possibility
so every obstacle is an opportunity for
you to step into the light
my mind is one
with god's mind
there's something here for me to learn
okay
and once you change your mind
you can face the obstacle with d vine
guidance
d vine
of the vine okay i didn't misspell that
d means of and vine because the vine is
connected to the branch and the branch
is connected to the tree we're not
adapted for
security and utopia we're adapted for a
certain amount of security because you
know we are vulnerable but mostly we
want to have one foot out where we don't
know what the hell is going on because
that's where you're alert and alive and
tense and with it and and you know i
think i believe this and i believe it
actually has something to do with the
hemispheric structure of the physiology
of your brain is because the right
hemisphere looks roughly adapted to what
you don't know and the left hemisphere
and this is a very this is an
oversimplification but a useful one
is adapted to the world that you do know
and the right place for you to be is
halfway between them because then you
can tell that that's what's so cool and
this tells you that this is actually
reality that's manifesting itself to you
you know that sense of active engagement
you have in the world when things are
working well for you you know where
you're where you should be at the right
time you're alert and on top of things
and engaged and you don't have much of a
sense of time and the sense of the
tragedy of life sort of recedes and
that's when you're that's when you've
got one foot when it's where it's secure
and one foot out in the unknown and your
brain signals to you that you're in the
right place by making what you're doing
meaningful
and that sense of meaning is actually a
neurophysiological signal that you've
got the forces of the cosmos properly
balanced in your being at that moment
and that's why it feels so good now what
else could it possibly be i mean
you know our our brain is capable of
looking beyond our vision that's what
it's for
and that sense of engagement there's no
reason to assume that that's anything
but a real signal and you can reduce it
you could say well
the problem with being where you know
only is that you don't know everything
and that's going to be a problem in the
future and the problem with being where
you know nothing is
that's just too much man like you know
you go into panic mode and because
anything can happen there and you can't
handle it
so you've got to mediate between those
two things you want to be secure enough
so that your physiology isn't revving
out of control and you want to be out
there in the unknown enough so that you
keep updating yourself constantly
constantly constantly and that's that's
the place where information flow is
maximized and you know that because
that's where you are when you're having
a really interesting conversation with
someone or you're gripped by a book or
you're really into a movie or maybe
something that you do as a
you know apart from your work or maybe
even in your work you're into it and
that's because you are in the right
place at the right time and your whole
nervous system is signaling that to you
and i would say that's the sort of place
that you should be all the time
of course you can't be because no one's
perfect but it's that's that's the
recreation of paradise on earth it's
something like it because you are in the
right place at the right time when that
is happening
and so we're mobile creatures right we
need to know where we're going because
all we're ever concerned about roughly
speaking is where we're going that's
what we need to know where are we going
what are we doing and why
it turns out that the way that we're
constructed neurophysiologically is that
we don't experience any positive emotion
unless we have an aim
and we can see ourselves progressing
towards that aim
it isn't precisely attaining the aim
that makes us happy
as you all know if you've ever attained
anything because as soon as you attain
it then the whole little game ends then
you have to come up with another game
right so it's it's sisyphus and that's
okay but but it does show that the
attainment can't be the thing that
drives you because it collapses the game
that's what happens when you graduate
from university it's like you're king of
the mountain
for one day and then you're like surf at
at starbucks for the next five years you
know so
yeah
so what happens is that that human
beings are weird creatures because we're
much more activated by having an aim and
moving towards it than we are by
attainment and what that means is you
have to have an aim and that means you
have to have an interpretation and it
also means that the nobler the aim
that's one way of thinking about it the
better your life and that's a really
interesting thing to know because you
know you've heard ever since you were
tiny that you should act like a good
person and you shouldn't lie for example
and you might think well why the hell
should i act like a good person and why
not lie i mean even a three-year-old can
ask that question because smart smart
kids learn to lie earlier by the way and
they think well
why not twist the fabric of reality so
that it serves your specific short-term
needs i mean that's a great question why
not do that why act morally if you can
get away with something and it brings
you closer to something you want well
why not do it these are good questions
it's not self-evident well it seems to
me tied in with what i just mentioned
it's like you destabilize yourself and
things become chaotic that's not good
and if you don't have a noble aim then
you have nothing but but shallow
trivial
pleasures and they don't sustain you and
that's not good because because life is
so difficult so much it's so much
suffering it's so complex it ends and
everyone dies and it's painful it's like
without a noble aim how can you
withstand any of that you can't you
become desperate and once you become
desperate things go
things go from bad to worse very rapidly
when you become desperate and so there's
the idea of the noble aim
and it's it's not something it's it's
something that's necessary it's the
bread that people cannot live without
right that's not physical bread it's the
noble aim and what is that
well
it's to pay attention it's to speak
properly it's to confront chaos it's to
make a better world it's something like
that
and that's enough of a noble aim so that
you can stand up without you know
cringing at the very thought of your own
existence so that you can do something
that's worthwhile to justify your
wretched position on the planet learning
to surrender all was the first big
lesson now many of you
uh have heard me tell the color purple
story of wanting wanting wanting praying
for it then finally at the moment when i
let it go and started singing i
surrender all
did the phone call come to be in
spielberg's office for an audition not
until i let it go though and just this
past week i had another surrender all
let it go moment i've lost a very
valuable piece of art
i'd gone to storage and somehow in the
move to renovate my house
it had been misplaced and so we've been
searching searching searching since last
april and last week i brought a crew of
seven people to the warehouse we're
opening every box every crate looking
all over for it everybody frantic i
actually sat down and prayed lord help
us find it help us find it nothing then
after three days straight of searching
i said okay
i have to do what i did over 30 years
ago with the color purple except that
that
piece of work is gone make peace with it
and move on and let me tell you in less
than an hour
we found it
and not in the place where seven people
were searching so that reinforced for me
this
ability to let it go
is what opens the door for other spaces
to enter
for a higher consciousness than your
worrisome thoughts so i invite you to do
that this week whatever is bothering you
worrying you open the space for
something higher than you to enter and
be able to say in the spirit of yourself
i
surrender all
today is a new day
today is a day for you to begin creating
a joyous fulfilling life
today is the day to begin to release all
your limitations
today is the day
for you to learn the secrets of life
you can change your life for the better
you already have the tools within you to
do this
these tools are your thoughts
and your beliefs
i will teach you how to use these tools
to improve the quality of your life
for those of you who are not familiar
with the benefits of positive
affirmations
i would like to explain a little about
them
an affirmation is really anything you
say or think
a lot of what we normally say and think
is quite negative and does not create
good experiences for us
we have to retrain our thinking and
speaking into positive patterns if we
want to change our lives
an affirmation opens the way
it is a beginning point of change
in essence you are saying to your
subconscious mind i am taking
responsibility
i am aware that there is something i can
do to change
when i talk about doing affirmations
i mean to consciously choose words that
will either help to eliminate something
from your life
or help to create something new in your
life
every thought you think and every word
you speak is an affirmation
all our self-talk is a stream of
affirmations
you are using affirmations every moment
whether you know it or not
you are affirming and creating your life
experiences with every word and every
thought
your beliefs are merely habitual
thinking patterns that you learned as a
child
many of them work very well for you
other beliefs may be limiting your
ability to create the very things you
may say you want
what you want and what you believe you
deserve may be very different
you need to pay attention to your
thoughts so you can begin to eliminate
the ones that are creating experiences
that you do not want in your life
please realize that every complaint is
an affirmation of something you think
you don't want in your life
every time you get angry you are
affirming that you want more anger in
your life
every time you feel like a victim you
are affirming that you want to continue
to feel like a victim
if you feel that life does not give you
what you want in your world then it is
certain you will never have the goodies
that life gives to others until you
change the way you think and talk
you are not a bad person for thinking
the way you do
you have just never learned how to think
and talk
the world is just now beginning to learn
that our thoughts create our experiences
your parents probably didn't know this
so they could not possibly teach it to
you
they taught you how to look at life in
the way that their parents taught them
so nobody is wrong
however it is time for all of us to wake
up and to begin to consciously create
our lives in a way that pleases and
supports us
you can do it i can do it we can all do
it you just need to learn how
so let's get to it
i will talk about affirmations in
general and then i will get to specific
areas of life and show you how to make
positive changes in your health or your
finances or your love life etc
once you learn how to use affirmations
then you can apply the principles in all
situations
some people say that affirmations don't
work
which is an affirmation in itself
when what they mean is they don't know
how to use them correctly
they may say my prosperity is growing
and think oh this is stupid i know it
won't work
which affirmation will win out the
negative one because it is part of a
long-standing habitual way of looking at
life
sometimes people will say their
affirmations once a day and then
complain the rest of the time
it will take a long time for
affirmations to work if it is done this
way
the complaining affirmations will always
win because there are more of them and
they are usually said with great feeling
saying our affirmations is only part of
the procedure what we do for the rest of
the day and night is even more important
the secrets to having your affirmations
work quickly and consistently is to
prepare the atmosphere for them to grow
in
affirmations are like seeds planted in
soil
poor soil poor growth
rich soil abundant growth
the more you can choose to think
thoughts that make you feel good the
quicker the affirmations work
think happy thoughts
it's that simple i don't believe in
toxic positivity i don't believe that
you just like put a positive spin on
things and things will disappear and be
fine that's not how the world works
there are very real challenges that you
may be facing you may be facing abuse
violence you may be up against
structural and systematic racism and
bias and discrimination you may be
facing extreme poverty you may be facing
all kinds of very real and traumatic
things in your life
simply putting a positive spin on things
will not change those very real
obstacles what it changes is you
when you change how you look at things
it changes your ability to deal with the
things in your life it changes your
ability to face hard things and it gives
you the courage and the confidence and
the resilience and the stamina to chip
away at these large obstacles or these
past experiences that created trauma or
negative self-talk it's going to give
you the ability to take the action that
you need and so when you hear me talk
about mindset i want you to understand
this doesn't make things disappear it
actually empowers you to be your
greatest self to face the stuff that's
very difficult you know because
confidence
courage resilience these are all things
that are inside you and you don't build
this stuff
in the high moments you build your
confidence and your courage and your
resilience in the low moments it's like
steel it's forged in the fire of your
life and so even in those moments where
you feel like life is punching you in
the face and you just want to give up
and you have that like i can't handle
this anymore and why does this keep
happening to me i am telling you do not
give up because you are building your
inner strength every step of the way
through these experiences that you're
facing in your life i'm not saying it's
fair i'm not saying you deserve it i'm
saying you have the power within you to
face whatever you're dealing with to
find your strength and to actually
change yourself and the situation and
the trajectory that you're on for the
better a merchant in the middle east was
once casually walking through a market
looking at things of interest that he
could buy
when his eyes spotted something
spectacular
something that he always cherished to
have
something that he already had a
huge collection of
it would be lovely to add this one to my
collection as well the merchant thought
it was a fine camo
up for sale at the marketplace
both the merchant and the camel seller
were great negotiators they went back
and forth and finally agreed upon a
price
the camel seller being very pleased with
his ability to get a fantastic prize
parted with the camo and the merchant
well he thought he had struck a
fantastic bargain and he proudly walked
back home with the latest addition to
his large livestock
when he reached home the merchant
realized that the padded saddle on the
camel was very heavy
he called his assistant to come and take
the saddle off from the camel
as the assistant removed the saddle he
found hidden under it a small
velvet pouch when he opened it he was
wonder struck to see that it was filled
with precious jewels
excited he said to the merchant sir
you brought a
camel home but look what came along with
it for free
the merchant was astonished to see the
high quality jewels sparkling in the
palms of the assistant
the merchant said to him
say
i bought only the camel
not the jewels i must immediately go
back and return these to the camel
cellar the assistant was like are you
kidding me sir if you keep them no one
will ever know the merchant headed right
back to the market and handed over the
velvet pouch back to the camel cellar
the camel seller had forgotten that he
had kept the jewels in the saddle to
keep them safe and was besides himself
with joy on having received them back
impressed with this gesture of the
merchant he made an offer that the
merchant could choose any one of the
jewels and keep it as a reward
the merchant replied i paid a fair price
just for the camel thank you for your
offer but i don't think i need any
reward
on the persistent insistence of the
camel cellar the merchant sheepishly
smiled and said actually when i decided
to bring the pouch back to you
i already took two of the most precious
jewels and kept them for myself
the camel cellar was a bit taken aback
by this confession and quickly emptied
the pouch to count the jewels
now
he was even more bewildered because all
the jewels were still there exactly the
same as before he sold the camel he
asked the merchant
all my jewels are here sir which two
jewels did you keep the two most
precious and lucky ones replied to the
merchant the two lucky stores that can
change one's life
my integrity and my self-respect
ladies and gentlemen when we live by
what is right we may lose a thing
but gain trust
when we live by what is right we may
lose a thing but sleep well when we live
by what is right we may lose a thing but
achieve deep satisfaction when we live
by what is right we may lose a thing but
acquire
great reputation when we live by what is
right we may lose a thing but inspire
others to live by what is right and
create a legacy which is why i always
say
integrity means
doing the right things
even when
no one
is watching now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the good deed
of the day this is something new i
believe that you're able to serve and it
feels so good to do something nice for
somebody else so good deed of the day
put down in the comments one thing that
you need help with that you're working
on you'd love some support or guidance
on and then two go comment on somebody
else's comment and give them some love
give them some support give them some
encouragement maybe give them some
connections try to help them solve that
problem even if it's saying i believe in
you that one little bit of encouragement
can be the difference between somebody
quitting and continuing on so the good
deed of the day in the comments below
write down one thing that you need help
on that you're struggling with that
you're working on and then part two is
go give love to somebody else in the
comments too and let them know that you
believe in them as well hard work is
your ticket in
hard work doesn't guarantee your success
but it's your ticket in there's nobody
who you look up to who you respect who
you want to be like who did not work
incredibly hard to get to where they're
at now people say work smart work smart
work yes
there's lots of people who work hard
and never get anywhere close to their
goals there's lots of people who work
incredibly hard who who stay earning
minimum wage their entire life because
they didn't work smart they were only
working hard but there's nobody who just
works smart and doesn't work hard
even if they're fooling you with their
pictures on instagram
it's that combination of working hard
plus working smart i've covered
most of these people i've hung out with
a lot of these people i see the
incredible smarts that they have in the
activities that they choose but also
just
the work ethic they have to show up
every day and stay consistent on their
goals
so in this video i'm gonna
try to give you some tips and steps and
how to actually do it like how do you
stay consistent how do you figure out
how to work hard but also work smart on
accomplishing your mission so
let's get it started first off you have
to actually love the thing right i mean
how many times have you started a
business because you thought it was
going to make you a lot of money
be honest i've done it too you started
business because you think it's going to
make you money
and then you quickly get bored of it
you quickly realize it's not making you
money
and you don't want to do it anymore
and you close it down and move on to the
next thing and so many people are just
opportunity hopping
jump to the next thing the next thing
and the next thing the next thing the
next thing without ever actually loving
any of the things and so you never you
never actually win you might make a
little bit of money here and there
you know you might be able to pay some
of your bills off it's great but you're
not living the life that you want
because you're just opportunity hopping
instead of actually finding the thing
that you love doing we're the number one
rule for success if you
watch any of my videos we've covered so
many people take my word for it or go do
your own research the number one number
one guys number one rule for success is
that you have to love what you're doing
you have to love the process the actual
work that you're doing
it doesn't feel like work because you
like it so much making videos doesn't
feel like work because i like it because
i like the process i like making it i i
like making this video more than
getting something like this right it's
great hey a million subscriber is
awesome or the other channel is great
but i like i like the feeling of making
this video knowing that you right now
are watching it
that means something to me i like it
that's why i keep going otherwise it's
crazy you know
10 000 videos plus later why like how do
you keep going because i like it
it doesn't feel like work to me i talk
about it when i do interviews you know
how people ask me how have you not burnt
out already like so many people are
burning out on youtube but it's not just
youtube it's entrepreneurship people
burn out of entrepreneurship not just
having a youtube channel why do you burn
out of entrepreneurship because you stop
actually liking there's too much of the
work that you're doing you don't like it
anymore
right there's too much of the work that
you're doing you might still love the
vision for where you're going if you
don't know the vision you got to get out
asap
but you might still love the vision but
you're just taking on too much
activity that you don't like doing
anymore
so when i'm talking to somebody on their
podcast i like i like doing interviews
it makes me happy it brings me joy to
try to
hit somebody else's audience right they
try to spread believe to an even wider
net
and so if i'm talking to somebody say
well what does this work for you because
in talking to you this doesn't work for
me
this is fun
i'm gonna leave this interview with more
energy than i came in
that's a sign that you're doing the
right thing so i like this thank you
you're you're giving me
you know i'm giving you content and
exposure for your channel but you're
giving me a gift because
this is fun you're giving me more energy
it doesn't feel like work
the second it starts to feel like work
you have to adjust and it might be it
might be a big adjustment maybe you
shouldn't be doing your business anymore
period because you just opportunity
hopping you don't actually love the
thing
or maybe you just need to make a minor
adjustment and realize okay this makes
sense as a strategy but it's just not
the right strategy for me i need to move
on and do something else even though it
works with some other people
it's not me i don't want to do it
so that's where we start transitioning
to working smart right so working hard
is you showing up every day working
towards your goals but that your purpose
means something to you and that the work
you do you actually enjoy and having fun
in
the working smart is then figuring out
there's so many different ways to win
inside your industry there's so many
different ways to win there's so many
people who have one
and there's not just one path this is
where we get locked up is feeling like i
have to do it this way but you don't
actually love doing it that way
and the second you start taking things
on because you think it's the smart
thing to do but you have no interest in
doing it you will never win you will
never win doing work that you hate it's
not going to happen you will never win
doing work that you hate you'll say that
you'll do whatever it takes you won't
you'll quit you'll give up on it because
you don't like it
chasing the goal alone is not enough you
have to actually enjoy the process of
getting to the goal that the process
becomes more important than the goal
gives you more satisfaction and
happiness and pleasure than hitting the
goal how many times have you hit a goal
and then been disappointed after right
he's like oh what's next
sometimes borderline depression right
ted turner's dad had a goal to hit a
million dollars he did it then he killed
himself because he thought things were
going to change but he realized his life
was still the same
so having goals are really good and
important but more important than the
goal is the process of accomplishing the
goal you have to actually like the work
you want to work on
and develop you you've got to up your
game on your program for you
the things that that you're going to
fortify yourself so you can be ready for
the fight
because if we don't know anything else
here's what we learned it ain't all
about the vision you got to be ready to
fight
therefore taking you the whole armor of
god that ye may be able to withstand in
the evil day in order to stand
you got to know you in fact most people
don't know you in a fight you know in
school you know one of the first things
they need to teach us in school that
life is a fight for territory
for peace of mind for health for your
relationships for your family for the
kind of life that you want to live
oh the reading writing and arithmetic oh
that's nice and that can't take you
where you want to go you can survive on
that but you can live on that
you have to have an expanded vision of
yourself we got to fight all the way to
the end because see i said yesterday
that life
is it's it's really
it's it's fascinating life is a fight
for territory
and once you stop fighting for what you
want
what you don't want
will automatically
take over it's a fight for territory
life is about
transformation life
it's about disruptions
life
it's about miracles
you you you are here to grow you must
die daily to who you are so you can give
birth to who you are to become
and there will be
interruptions along the way life is like
a box of chocolates you never know what
you're going to get that's all i got to
say about that
and it's about miracles
you have miracle working power the fact
that you're still here so this is
different
this is very
very
different
and and so as you look at yourself look
at your goals look at your dreams you
gotta have a game plan for you you gotta
have a game plan for your mind i wanna
start with two questions that i really
want you to think about
and the two questions are
what should i be afraid of today
and who's to blame
what should scare me and whose fault is
it
to me
these are the most
profoundly dangerous
questions that we center our lives
around
um
and what they are indicators
to me with their indicators of is a
culture of scarcity
a culture of not enough
and when you think about think about any
milieu in your life think about
education
what are we supposed to be afraid of
and who's to blame
politics the economy social issues
i guarantee you if you turn on the news
or open to paper today the focus would
be
here's why you should be afraid and
here's whose fault it is
and it
and what's interesting to me about that
is it's not just at a cultural level or
a community level that stuff happens in
my house every week
every week with my husband i talk to him
about what we should what should be you
know why we should be fearful and whose
fault it is mostly it's his
um
but you know if something doesn't go
well at my daughter's school
then i'm like oh my god
this is this is going to have huge
implications for university
and we should be terrified right now
that she's not getting cursive i know
she's four
but this is still relevant
it's indicative of scarcity so let's
talk about what scarcity culture is
and what it looks like scarcity culture
i think is best understood with a simple
question of
never enough
and you can fill in the blanks
never good enough safe enough certain
enough perfect enough
relevant enough and perhaps i think one
of the most dangerous and insidious
messages today
is never extraordinary enough
somehow
in the world we live in today
an ordinary life has become synonymous
with a meaningless life
um and it has huge i mean and i've
watched it happen not only as a
researcher i'm a qualitative researcher
so i sit across from people and look in
their eyes and i have a good sense of
what's going on in their lives but as a
university professor who's been teaching
for the last 17 years
it's been very clear to me that
extraordinary means relevant
and the top one is is the big one for
all of us personally never good enough
you know which is shame
which we all have
on occasion that sense
that we're not smart enough good enough
perfect enough loved enough promoted
enough
we're not enough
so what we do in response to scarcity
culture i think all of us every day
is this
we wake up in the morning and we armor
up
and we we put it on and we say i'm going
to go out in the world
i'm basically just going to kick some
ass
i'm not going to let anyone see who i am
and in doing so i can protect myself
against the things that hurt the most
judgment criticism fear blame ridicule
i'm gonna armor up and i'm gonna be safe
and we rationalize and we convince
ourselves that this armor is really
smart
and we use a lot of different things to
armor too
perfectionism
intellectualizing
but if you get really really clear about
what we're doing every morning when we
wake up and decide to armor
it's this simple
this is what we're protecting
we're protecting
[Music]
being hurt
for a very simple reason that no one
really wants to talk about which is this
love
belonging
irreducible needs of men women and
children
in the absence of love and belonging
there is always suffering
and so what we believe is that we can
protect our sense of being lovable
and being acceptable and being worth
connection
with armor
here's the very worst news from my
research
the news that above all other i did not
want to hear
is simply this and i don't even want to
say it to you because i think it's mean
to say it
but it's so true
and it's simply
our capacity
for wholeheartedness
can never be greater than our
willingness to be brokenhearted
which is a terrible thing
but a truthful thing
that we can only love and be loved
as much as we are willing to have our
heart broken
and so when we move to the world like
this
and with our partners with our children
with our friends in classrooms with the
people who work for us with the people
we work for
there are tremendous casualties many
aspects to this fundamentally if you
keep your life energies very exuberant
now you will see the sleep quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be overleading
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only two meals a day ten
in the morning seven in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world
and we are seven days 365 days we don't
know what's a vacation because we're
enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so
they never go on a vacation there is no
break there's no sunday monday nonsense
nothing every day something is happening
endlessly but you will see
people are very energetic healthy sleep
is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things
a certain amount of energy and a certain
amount of time
when it comes to time
it is ticking away for all of us at the
same pace clock doesn't run slowly for
me faster for you there is no such thing
whether you are busy you are lazy you
are sleeping you are doing useful things
or useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there's no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for a thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death
so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day
how long do you want to die in a day you
really must use this word for yourself
don't tell anybody i'm going to die
for yourself how long do i want to die
in a day
eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you're dead
in 24 hours eight hours you're dead
means one third of your life dead
another four hours goes into eating
sleeping eating toilet bath this that
where is the time to live i'm
asking so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time we spend
away so much energy focusing on the
success of others that we don't spend
enough energy focusing on developing our
own success imagine all the energy
you're channeling towards someone else's
success and just going how comes they
have that and you could channel that and
say actually how do i create meaningful
relationships in my life how do i create
relationships that i'm happy about just
that switch completely changes the
course of your life right completely
that's all the series that we need to
make and that's the switch where your
intelligence leads the mind rather than
the mind leading the intelligence when
the mind leads the intelligence the mind
gets caught in that web of
the mentality that oh i don't have
enough i'm not good enough and that's
one of the interesting things that
there's no limit on the amount of
holidays you can take there's no limits
on the amount of billionaires in the
world there's no limits on the amount of
millionaires in the world there's no
limits on the amount of successful
people in the world there really isn't
right there's nowhere where it says that
there will only be
a hundred millionaires on this planet
there will only be ten billionaires on
this planet there aren't rules like that
they're not written anywhere but we tell
ourselves there are we make ourselves
feel that there are so we constantly put
ourselves into this victim mindset where
we feel oh but that doesn't happen to me
that doesn't work for me right that's
not going to happen for me so we need to
remove that and that's the mind leading
when the mind leads it tells us there's
a limit on success there's a limit on
this there's a limit on that if that
person has it i can't have it and that's
not true at all if your friend just went
on a nice holiday to mauritius or
thailand or wherever it is in the world
that doesn't stop you okay you can't
have their seat on the plane that
they're booked given but there's so many
other seats there's so many other
flights and we've got to start
recognizing that we've got to start
connecting with that and that's what we
shift from the mind leading our dialogue
to the intelligence leading our dialogue
the intelligence leads with insight let
me be compassionate to up towards myself
let me be conscious let me care the mind
leads with impulse or ignorance and
takes us down the wrong route imagine
you've got two friends you're sitting
with two friends right one is the mind
one is your intelligence your
intelligence will be stronger based on
what you read what you absorb that tofu
soaked in your intelligence what you're
taking in every day what you're thinking
about that's when your intelligence gets
stronger it's the one that you feed
right the one that you feed are you
feeding your mind or are you feeding
your intelligence ask yourself that
question right now right how many of you
are feeding your intelligence on a daily
basis versus your mind the one you feed
more gets stronger right the one you
feed more gets stronger the one you feed
with more intensity more absorption gets
stronger if you find that the
relationships around you have toxic
outcomes then i want you to look at
where is the breakdown is the breakdown
in communication is the breakdown in how
you communicate the words you're using
is the breakdown in who you choose to be
around
it's the breakdown in the engagement of
what you're talking about what i've
learned is that if you're not talking
about things that are high enough and
big enough
things that are inspiring enough you
will slip into the smallness
every single time if you don't choose an
intentionally high evolving encouraging
conversation you will slip into the
cracks you will slip into those crevices
of smallness and petty and until you get
people trained that you're going to live
up here without telling them i need you
to know it's not an announcement it's a
way of being and so what do you choose
to participate in it's a stepping over
your desire to hear smallness
gossip
negative feedback it's when someone is
engaging in negative feedback about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook
did you stop the conversation
did you say hold on i don't want to
engage in speaking negatively of them at
all why don't you have a conversation
with them it's course correcting
behaviors in your space at the risk at
the risk of losing the relationship but
what you basically do is is you say
here's where i play
here is where i live i'm not visiting
this high road of integrity i'm not
visiting this high road of conscious
thinking and awareness and respect and
humility and and honoring the dignity of
people i don't visit this place
i live here
i don't visit this place
i live here
and in a loving way anyone that's
engaging with you has two choices
they either engage with you here
or they choose to engage with someone
else
now if you find
that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger or
you're in a moment of resentment or
you're in a moment of hurt then you're
not living in your highest integrity you
just visit every now and again when you
come to this channel uh-oh i see my my
my shantae coming out right now shantae
is my middle name it's what i do when i
start getting real edgy because i really
want you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside
and then you don't leave your conscious
neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as yours
people will rise to the occasion or
they'll choose not to rise and they'll
pick other people to be with and hang
with and i know that sounds easier said
than done because some of the people who
are playing at a lower level might be in
family it might be and that's fine too
you can love people
it doesn't mean you have to spend tons
and tons and tons of time if that time
costs you something
spend as much time as you can
spend as much time it serves you spend
as much time as they will allow you to
spend but never leave this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are you
don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line and
supporting you to either recognize are
you the toxic element are you
surrounding yourself in toxic element is
to make a commitment where you live
where am i living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what i do
slip into that small place okay own it
that's conscious awareness
that's powerful
own it and then go where do i want to be
and then what's the distance between
here and there and what do i have to do
to get there
what i have to say no to do i have to
participate in what i have to ask
forgiveness for what i have to clean up
what relationships require cleaning up i
had to deal with a lot of fear and you
don't know what it's like every day
you're walking and you don't know the
next moment you're going to fall i've
had several falls
and falls are literally what will do it
so it's constant fear and i just won't
let it affect me i push past my limits i
do things that i'm not supposed to do
i take hikes even though i have to hold
on to somebody to do it people think i'm
crazy so i had to deal with my fear
mastery taught me that repetition doing
something over and over and over again
like any kind of skill
learning a skill like basketball
whatever
leads to something so every day
just using my left hand instead of my
right hand forcing myself and slowly
getting used to it that taught me a lot
and then the laws of human nature
you know i have a
one thing that when you have a stroke it
affected the right side of my brain
which
destroyed the left side of my body
and supposedly when the right side of
your brain is damaged it tends to make
you more emotional
and i've definitely become more
emotional so i've had to learn to
control some of my anger some of my
impatience
some of my frustration and obviously the
laws of human nature a lot about that
and the last chapter is about having to
deal with death
and so
with all the things i'm dealing with and
all the kind of
god damn it why can't i do that i have
to keep reminding myself i'm alive
i'm going to write another book
the birds are out there chirping it
could have been a much different story
last month
six weeks ago was the second year
anniversary of the stroke and i had this
thought
this could have been the second
anniversary of my death wow
and what people would be like gathering
together or maybe they would maybe they
wouldn't
but you know it would be like the
anniversary of my death but it's not
i've been given a second lease and i
have to think about that every single
day i didn't know why i was born this
way i didn't believe i would actually
become independent
married now with four kids traveling
around the world to talk about hope
was really
fantasy i i actually felt like at one
stage i had no hope for myself no
purpose how old was that how old were
you when you had that yeah age six seven
eight were the bigger questions that i
asked myself
saying why am i here
why did this happen to me and i went to
school and you know kids would come up
and they would tease me and i'll try
flip it around you know on a humorous
level and say you know they asked me
what happened i just say cigarettes
you know just the oldie but a goodie
yeah i'll go all right
and you know i love pulling pranks you
know today and and uh doing crazy things
like getting my friends to put me in the
overhead compartment of airplanes and
dressed me up as a pilot that's amazing
yeah it's been it's been fun um
travel now 74 countries and and the the
universal truth of
asking yourself why am i here what's my
purpose what's my value what's my
identity am i defined by what other
people tell me
am i defined by my previous failures and
what i can or cannot do
and so that whole
understanding of who you really are and
the self-awareness that we all need to
have and embracing who you are embracing
that you are unique that there's not
another you
and that's why my parents always said
nick there's not another you do your
best keep going don't give up if you
want to learn to start your day
positively check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there and perspective simply reminds us
to go to 50 000 feet on a bad day and
count our blessings
perspective simply reminds us that
things could be a lot worse